what's the deal with airplane peanuts
dude i remember being in school and uh
statistics or something and it was like
it was it was freshman year in college
and the teachers like statistically
speaking it was 1400 kids in the class
it was like
two of you guys will die in car
accidents one of you guys would be a
registered sex offender she was right
wasn't she no i remember standing up and
going not it that's what i said
not it yeah that's good though get the
[ __ ] out of here
i don't think you would go on ellen i
don't know i i just imagine if she asked
you to dance
would you go out there dancing all the
way down the aisle
no theo vaughn
and that dj and the dda is like what's
up ceo and you have to do that thing
you're like what up dog yeah you gotta
do that stanley
hey uh hey diverse person i can just
even imagine yeah i don't even need to
know who the dj is like hey diverse
person he's like what up what up
but would you go on there you would on
ellen yeah no dude i used to leave city
grill in tucson arizona dude i get in
the car bro i'd put an abbey road out of
cassette tape dude
yeah cassette tape bro and i'd put that
in and somebody stole my passenger seat
out of my car dude and i didn't give a
check the whole seat yeah you had a race
car at that point then
yeah it was just like if you got in the
front you had to sit in the back you
know it was like that
and i would just put that in and uh one
song and a cigarette i could time it
where it would last me until exactly i
pulled into my mom's driveway damn
pretty good didn't that feel good god it
felt good man what was your cigarette of
choice um usually a winston or a doral a
winston what are you my father that's
insane that's what my dad smoked i mean
winston and his brother smoked
unfiltered paul malls
that's a that's a veteran of war oh yeah
like you ha it's almost like you have to
go to nam to smoke palm oil they check
you at the store
like you go to nam he's like yeah okay
you can have unfiltered but my uncle
used to smoke nonfiction they show you a
picture of like a uh vietnamese guy if
you cringe a little yeah yeah
yeah you're good
you're jagging
[Laughter]
what are your last two words if you're
gonna crash like it's
barreling down towards the ground and
the pile is like this is it this is it
we can't we're gonna [ __ ] go two
words that's all you have what do you
say
[ __ ] man
you'd say you ate a lot of meal out of
the [ __ ] that's good [ __ ] man that's
really good
but i would my my words would be knew it
knew it
knew it
just to get with it
it's just a [ __ ] with everyone's head on
the plane
right it
is just to [ __ ] with everyone's
why do you tell us i love that idea
no but you know what you know what i
think about all the time
and i was with my [ __ ] wife on this
flight but it was getting so bumpy
there was a really attractive girl
sitting across the aisle and i thought i
think i would kiss my wife first but
then i would also go kiss that hot girl
because i just i thought about that i
thought if we die
i'm going to get one on my wife and i
got to get one on this strange hobby
yeah she's it's that'll be it i'll never
have this again dude i would i think
probably stand up in front of everybody
maybe stand on my seat and just
open my ass up to everybody that's back
behind me
he's a jewish diamond dallas page really
he's jewish huh is he jewish howard
stern oh god i'm not listening anymore i
didn't know yeah i didn't know
imagine 25 years
oh no
no
his dad wore brown onesies all the time
and uh
those dickies ones these full bodies i
remember them yeah yeah where are they
now why can't we have those now now it's
so comfortable now it's considered
cultural appropriation you wear a brown
onesie dog
you're going to prison you're going to
prison
lock you up for life you're doing hard
times
dude the cops will beat you just for
[ __ ] putting one on
i don't like chatty people yeah i don't
like to sit when someone wants to engage
with me like airplanes or anywhere where
you stuck with somebody yeah
i don't want to chat
i don't want to chat with you man i'm
not a chatty guy one lady i remember one
time i had pretty bad body gas on a um
flight right you were you were were you
letting it out slow well there was
nothing i could do it was almost like
something had just
i don't know like a ghost was in me and
didn't want to come out all at once
and
there was a lady next to me and i kept
blaming it on a baby you know because i
had a baby nearby [ __ ] babies
yeah and it's a girl too first i thought
it was a boy then it was a girl baby
then i felt so bad you know there is
something [ __ ] up about blaming that
on a girl baby yeah it's kind of yeah
that's mean but then at one point the
lady was really buying into that it was
this baby creating this scent so she
kept looking at the baby yeah and the
lady was getting so pit the lady next to
me getting so pissed at this [ __ ]
baby and then one time brother was once
she goes oh that one was warm
[Laughter]
and i was like god i gotta get some help
from myself sometimes when i have to
fart on airplanes i'll get up and on the
way to the bathroom i'll fart through
the aisle
oh my god
that's
one of my favorite things to do
i don't like any of those people on the
plane anyway
i'm like any of those humans i feel like
every time you get on any airplane they
they call that go in a jersey if you
fart down the middle of the eye
[Laughter]
that's the turnpike i take the turnpike
all the way to the bathroom i like to
fart go to the bathroom wash my hands
and then wait about a minute and then
when i come out you know people in the
aisles are doing this yeah
yeah and i walk by and i go ugh and they
then they then they think i think it's
them and they go like this
pig i still don't understand why some of
the podcast people do not make a
wrestling
script
with this i know when you talk about
this i don't have any wrestling in my
blood though
who cares yeah but i don't i don't even
enjoy it it's not for me then you can
still do it have you seen wrestling dude
i know but there's something about
wrestling characters i don't like ty
you've ever been angry at a costume
party yeah that's wrestling bro i know i
mean
no i have i got no fight with a guy at a
costume party that's wrestling dude it's
just the halloween yeah but we really
fought yeah oh that's good we're really
fun
then that's not right we've really got
no fistfight with the mask thing it's
kind of like well
i think i have the one that works but i
don't know yes some people have on the
carpentry ones people have the asbestos
one the doc the real doctor won the end
yeah 95 that's like the real thing but
then
people getting pulled into surgery they
don't that work at a spc that works
walking past i worked at a humane
society sir we need you now
no i'm just i'm going to work i'm going
to known as empanadas yeah i'm here for
drywall
next thing you know that guy's in there
spackling somebody's kidney shut
you look so religious do people tell you
that a lot i i i look you know what
you're very catholic helpful people
would say so catholic like like church
people look like you could ask them for
favors or ask them for directions and
you have that youth pastor beard going
to people always can come yeah people
come up to me and they go tell tell me
what the day is going to bring yeah
i can't tell you
more people ask me for directions than
you can ever imagine really and i always
always always always lie yeah i don't
think i've ever given a real direction
in my life
i think people say hey how do you get to
hollywood and highland yeah i was like
go down la brea as far as you can go
dude i lie every time people ask me
one thing i've never given a real
direction i think that's my favorite
thing to do in l.a for now we'll keep
doing king and the singer it's just when
i come back we'll do you know we'll
record two episodes yeah or um
yeah he's a snake charmer now that guy
i mean is he sponsored by bicycles it's
it's like i can't not see a bike post
but and segora is now into bikes now
it's like a crossover thing
well it's just one thing to the next i'm
gonna sell you coffee i'm gonna sell
your neckwear right you know i'm gonna
sell you uh he's like a traveling
salesman yeah cbd oil dude
remember i remember when brendan told me
that he him and his buddies found a cbd
mine somewhere and i was like
underground cbd oil bro it's plentiful
it's just pouring out estonia oh like
look bro that's not the angle you want
to take if you're gonna try to sell this
thing okay
he's unbelievable though he can sell ice
eskimos he's he's so good at finding
stuff you know how many people buy thick
boy gear it's it's insane yeah
everything it says so many my dad has a
thick guy stick boy shirt my dad's like
we're starting to bike we just want to
get out and just just we want to be
thick boys
trying to find snakes in chicago
[Music]
you always do this to jeff you do this
to me too yeah you he almost does the
same thing to me every time i come on
you say that's somebody's stepson yeah
which is so funny you know why because
that's true i am a rhythm
yeah yeah oh wow i didn't know that yeah
i got to step down you just have that
step you have that steps on anger in you
are always talking about violence that's
true and all right
or step sons all redheads or steps kids
have to be because the original father
was never going to stick around yeah
once they see the red hair the original
father was like
mine got into drugs and they're like
what is this something out of the garden
come out of here put it back put it back
the guy around the corner the liquor
store guy i forgot it one time and he
was like it's okay i don't care come it
doesn't matter yeah and i i did one of
these he's back there making a bomb he's
like yeah
i'm not
he's like nobody blow up this whole
block in 45 minutes don't worry about it
he wants you to give a [ __ ] it's really
hard to think nothing exists it's really
strange once you've touched enough it'd
be strange to go to that many places and
eat different people's foods and listen
to their language their culture their
problems their happiness their sadness
and then still go
no this is all an accident yeah i just
it seems strange
you have every right to feel that way if
that's how you [ __ ] feel i think it
just seems a little lost now if you grew
up in this very tiny little bubble and
you never left your bubble that's all
you knew and saw
yeah maybe it's more feasible to me but
we when we travel for a living even
traveling here just in the u.s yeah you
go enough places you go wow it's a
different it's a different world just a
state away people feel and think and
view
differently in just one one little state
away just go to [ __ ] arizona
different state nevada different state
colorado diff very different i mean that
to me starts to you start to see
different lines of people's lives and to
me it makes me go well something's got
to be i don't know what it is i'm not
smart enough but i know it's nothing no
and we may know one day or joe rogan
might tell us rogan does know but and
it's annoying he keeps it in that
[ __ ] pod thing he sleeps in that
water thing that's where he gets the
drippings of knowledge come from that
oh dude i saw him one time eating things
out of eating facts out of a glowing bag
one time really totally because i've
heard this and i've never seen it before
totally man it's in his glove he's
endless you know he says he loves to
play pool it's not the crack of the
balls gives him the secrets
yeah i've heard it a few times and i
think it's like zeus with the planets
that's exactly right when they smash
then he gets all this knowledge it's
really insane like is this do i use this
one to break he's like no that's neptune
that goes back in the formation
they put out so many false statistics to
us when we were kids i feel like because
we're we're in this similar yeah so you
look blind if you jerk off into the moon
you go blind cross your eyes too long
you go blind i remember i remember the
worst one was this is something i've
talked about before
everybody this is what this was in
school in sex ed class everybody is
gonna get herpes i remember them saying
that they were like one out of four one
out of four yep let me tell you i know
four people and i don't think they have
herpes i don't know why they think
everyone is gonna they used to tell you
we're gonna get hiv
they oh everybody had hiv you were gonna
get my ads yeah you were gonna get aids
dude they tried to stop football at our
school because of hiv because there was
some kid have it in case of blood yeah
that's cr that is crazy [ __ ] you would
have to i had a conversation about this
too someone was like well you know it's
easier to get than you think i was like
no bro it's harder to get than you
[ __ ] thing dude you have to really
you have to yeah you have to beat
yourself up and then [ __ ] somebody when
you've definitely been on just gotten
out of a fire almost right and then you
might not get aids yeah here's the best
way that i look at it magic johnson's
wife doesn't have aids yeah
how and he's the all-time leader in
assists
you think he didn't
you think he didn't try to [ __ ] push
it over to her all the way to the hole i
don't get that come on hey let me ask
you a question yeah if it's about
brendan it's not okay
i don't know that's the answer
this is always like dude brenda no no no
no i don't want to know about i don't
know you know i don't want to know you
know
what am i going to ask you what a shoe
size is i i know what do i need to know
about the guy no i don't know eric
griffin i was talking the other day he's
like i'm not going to do [ __ ] that i
don't want to do i'm not going to be
nice to people that aren't nice to me
i'm not i'm not going to do things that
don't
make me feel right good and healthy and
happy yeah because he said i was doing
things for other people that didn't
respect me and didn't like me didn't
appreciate me and he said i'm no longer
going to do that a beautiful man bro
yeah
for his size and his height
yeah and his body style man he has a
very rare body style it is you know he
looks like he could play power forward
underwater that's what he has that style
comic you know what i'm saying though
is brendan's son who had the idea
in dave
for you guys to have a bath scene
and you wash his back
there's a scene in the dave show where i
get in the tub with him and we're naked
and i wash his back we are really naked
in the chute yeah and you know what that
wasn't supposed to be on camera that was
that was a moment of dave and i kind of
having a bonding and they put it on the
show and i don't know if i appreciated
that i think they went they kind of went
above and beyond
um artistic integrity there because we
said we're kind of working the
characters we're trying to figure out
what we need from each other in the
scene so i would it was a long day it
was the end of the day i said i'm going
to take a bath in this house that we
were shooting and he said i'd love to
take a bath as well there was only one
bath i said we'll share a bath
but i want a closed set they put cameras
in there damn it's a little disturbing
but that's what the business does yeah
they're invasive nothing like putting
two men together and getting them naked
yeah in this town and this in this town
that's that's really what happens yeah
you know and they filmed it and it was
my choice and
i don't enjoy that they filmed it and
put it out there dude i'll tell you a
story that happened to me i remember i
just remember this when i first got into
town
some man set me up with a guy who was an
agent right some agent guy i know what
this is he's like i'll take you to this
party or something so he takes me to a
party cuba gooding jr is there so i'm
all excited he's always there yeah then
the guy's gonna give me a ride drop me
back off my place doesn't even have a
car yet right and i remember the guy
saying if you grab my dick while i drive
my car will go faster and did it uh i
didn't touch him oh but i remember just
didn't want to see if it could go fast
but we've been doing a little bit of
coke you know and i remember thinking uh
first i was like that's insane i don't
you know that sounds
you know that sounds fake yeah i don't
know if i don't know if there's a
correlation between his penis i didn't
even realize that the guy was trying to
be
perverted or homoerotic or anything i
didn't realize any of that i just
thought oh this guy he has a big car
he's a gearhead this guy's a real
gearhead yeah yeah yeah
but dude i said it twice and then i
remember i remember just having to stand
up for myself you know yeah at some
point i love women dude i gotta i still
had a picture of my girlfriend in my
wallet showed him you know look at
shannon but he didn't want to see him
huh he didn't you know it killed him bro
yeah he's like you sure that's not shawn
yeah that's not a shawn but i forgot
about that man i guess it's that kind of
town where they want you to be in a
bathtub with a man you got brand new
shoes on by the way you got some clean
adidas yeah these are in honor of my
buddy billy conforto is a friend of mine
that passed away oh rest in peace yeah
his birthday just passed and so
every year i'll get myself a pair of
these around his birthday and wear him
for you know a couple months kind of how
do you die
he
uh
drove into a
like an embankment kind of like a cement
structure you know good god was he drunk
high was he oh he's high well he was
semi-high he was on
let me see he was on pills i think he
was on like uppers and downers somewhere
in between yeah and he just
he had a long run man he'd been running
from just running from all of it
forever dude he's the first person that
taught me how to throw a frisbee he was
there when
when princess diana died he told me
princess diana was
and uh he was probably one of the top
you know i don't want to say
he's one of the top probably homosexual
prize fighters boxers in america
when do you think you die man
what do i think i die yeah honestly i
think i live longer than i'm supposed to
wow i just had a vision you don't
and i'm not even joking bro i don't mean
that in a bad way i love you and
everything but i just when am i gonna go
37.
bro that's in like a year and a half
sorry man
yeah
that's crazy
[Music]
[Music]
you